There
are
some scientists who say that the universe that we inhabit is not the only universe
there is. There are alternate
universes. They say that these universes arise from the subatomic realm
of quantum physics. Here's how they say it works. Every time a quantum event happens,
it produces all of its possible results. This is like saying if you flip a coin,
it comes up heads, but it also comes up tails.
Since those two results are mutually exclusive, the flipping of the coin splits the
universe into two alternate universes: the heads universe and the tails universe.
And since
quantum events are happening all the time, it means that alternate universes are bubbling up
continually. They're always being created, splitting off from ours. And these alternate universes
are real. They're not just figments of the imagination. They're complete, whole, real
things. I know this is true because I experienced an alternate universe.
I was driving in my Volkswagen van
up to a tai chi camp in upstate New York a couple of summers ago.
I bought the Volkswagen van when I'd quit my job a few years previously. I bought
the van because I quit the job as a custom database application
engineer. This was not a job that I really had intended to become. When I was a
kid, that's not what I thought I was going to
be. It's just sort of the job I happened into, and I always thought of it as
the work I was doing before I was going to find my real
work. But when I got close to about forty, I suddenly thought, oh my God.
This could be it. This could be what I end up doing. This could be on my tombstone.
Tom Weiser. Custom database application engineer. Wrote
well-optimized queries.
Many
customers satisfied. And I thought, no, that can't be it. That cant 't all there is. And
I quit the job without really knowing what I was going to do next.
And I knew that what I should do was to take my skill set and to make a
lateral move to a career path that was more appropriate,
but I I really didn't want to do that. I didn't want to be so logical. I actually wanted something
more magic. I wanted to be like the guy in the fairy tale
that trades the cow for the magic
beans. And I know that that's a bad deal. I know
that the cow's a better investment.
The cow's going to pay off in the long term but, but, but, but if the magic beans work out,
you're in a whole new story, so. So I quit the
job and I bought a Volkswagen Pop Top Camper van. And I drove
around the country, and what I thought was, OK.
I'm not going to make a lateral move. I am going to just drive around the country. And I'm gonna open
myself up to whatever may come. And then what I'm going to do is going to arise organically.
I'm gonna find my next pad there by the side of the road in Arizona. I'm going to pick it up and bring it back to
New York.
So I drove around the country. Twenty-five thousand miles. Eight months. And when I got
back to New York,
I had no clue. I really didn't know, and it left me
very
vulnerable to the New York question. The first question anybody asks, which
is, "So, what do you do?" I didn't know.
I didn't know, I didn't have a good answer and it made me feel really embarrassed because everybody knows
what they do. Everybody does, and I thought I should too.
So when I was driving the Volkswagen van up to tai chi camp the other summer, I felt
very relieved because in camp, I know what I do.
I do the camp thing. I do what's at camp, and I don't know if you know this, but there are a lot of camps
for adults that are out there. I found them when I was driving around the
country. There are tai chi camps and yoga camps and and birdwatching camps.
There's even a camp where you can dress up in armor and joust.
All the things that give us joy and that we tend to demean with the name hobby.
Those are the things that are, that are celebrated in
camp. And when people go to camp, they are so lit up. They are finally getting to do
that thing, the thing they love. It's like, yes.
I finally get to joust. I don't have time for that anymore. Really.
So I was going up to camp and feeling pretty good about it. Now I decided on the way, I would
stop into Ithaca. I'd heard that it was a kind of a neat town. So I pulled off the highway into
Ithaca,
and it's on the southern shore of Lake Cayuga. There's flat land and then
these hills, and it has a very particular microclimate there, which allows hippies
to survive. All the stores have names like It Takes a
Village or Hemp Unlimited.
And the, and the children are all completely multi-ethnic, and only wear cloth organic diapers.
It was really something. I drove around like sort of like Disney Hippieland, just watching it, And then I drove up
the hill, up toward Cornell,
which has these stately buildings on the hilltop. And as I drove onto the campus,
I had this standing sensation, and I suddenly was pierced with a vision of an alternate universe.
My alternate
life. I thought, oh my God. I was supposed to go to
Cornell.
If I'd gone to Cornell I would have studied animal behavior. And right now, I'd be
a professor of evolutionary biology. I'm a professor of
evolutionary biology and I've got a wife.
She's got dark hair. She's really smart. And I'm a professor with a
wife, and we've got two kids. They like to sing. It
was this completely realized vision of this alternate life, and it looked so
good. Alternate Ithaca Tom, he'd made these great choices.
It was really working out. And I drove around in a kind of
a wash of nostalgia for this life I hadn't had. It was like,
wow, there's the Human Ecology Center. I did all my grad work there.
And there was this funky cottage that I used
to live in where I had six roommates, and we had a chore wheel and ate brown rice.
And there was
these gorges that we used to do drum circles in and songs to the Goddess, and it was...
And there was this woman that looked just like my wife would have looked when I would have met her.
I was overwhelmed by it. I couldn't stand to stay there any longer. I drove off the
campus. I fled Ithaca and flew to tai chi camp. But alternate
Ithaca Tom came with me. Now, at camps, I tend to really have a
good time. I laugh a lot, I joke a lot,
especially in tai chi camp, where the residents are kind of serious and slow-moving.
I can't help but kind of tease them. And in
this particular camp, the teacher said that we were going to be meditating
every morning from seven to
eight. And she was looking for a volunteer. Someone, a musician, that
would wander the hallways playing an instrument or singing to wake up the residents.
I'm not a morning person. And so I thought, oh. So I have a choice here. Either it's
going to be 6:30, I'll be lying in my bed really grumpy while some asshole
sings outside my
door, or I could be the singing
asshole.
For the rest of that week, I was the singing asshole of the camp. Every morning, I would I would roam the
halls, singing lustily, waking up all my
fellow tai chi players. And the the people there saw me laughing
and singing, and they said, "Tom, it's really great to have you here. You're so happy. You're such a happy guy." And I thought,
and I thought 'Yeah, you think I'm happy, but you haven't seen alternate Ithaca Tom. I've seen him.
He's
happy'. And the fact that he was so much happier than me was making me miserable.
And I kept looking at everybody else's life and comparing myself to them. And I remember having
lunch with a woman who was in her 60s, and she was a calligrapher. And she was about to have her
first grandchild. She was really excited, and I
thought, maybe calligraphy. That could be it. And
then there was this other guy, and he had studied tai chi when he was in his 20s, and now he was a sales rep at Dell.
And I
thought, damnit, if I had studied tai chi in my 20s, maybe I could be a sales rep at Dell now.
I've never wanted to be a sales rep, but I was just getting carried away. That feeling that I was
in the wrong life, I was is in the wrong place. I couldn't shake it. I really tried
to absorb the lesson of tai chi, which is to be present, just relax.
Accept what's coming to you and be present here. But I thought, yeah, yeah, that would be easy. It's so much
easier to accept where you are, if only you're in the right place.
Eventually camp was over and I left. I drove back to New York. And as I was driving
over the George Washington Bridge I could still hear alternate Ithaca Tom. He was hanging around me,
haunting me like a ghost. And I thought, oh God. I need professional
help. So I made an appointment with the family psychic.
This
is the guy that's done readings for all of my siblings and my cousins. And I went to see him, and he's
an astrologer, so he did out my chart. And this time, he was very interested
in this polarity that he saw. He said, "You have Saturn in the mid-heaven. And
this marks you as a person who could be very organizational. The organizational man,
the hierarchical one.
The corporate guy, the dad, the provider. Not particularly sexy, but a straight up
guy. On the other hand, there's Pisces in the sun, and they're
squared with each other. You can't resolve them. Piscean, the dreamer, the mystic. The guy that's
the artist, never quite pinned down, never quite in a
relationship. And you have to balance these two. You have to choose one or the other."
And normally, I love to hear this kind of thing. This is the great thing about going to a psychic, is
that for an hour, they just talk about me.
It's so interesting.
But this time, I was so caught up with alternate Ithaca Tom, I couldn't really appreciate it
all, so I just blurted out what had happened to me. And I asked
him, "What does this mean?" And the psychic said, "Well, this represents
a fundamental choice that you've made in your life. You could have been the
hierarchical guy. But you chose to be the Piscean. If you had
decided to be an academic, you would have been very successful.
There's no doubt that the university structure would have raised you up. You probably would be married, have
kids." I thought, "Oh, shit. Alternate Ithaca Tom made the right
choices." "But ", the psychic said, "if you had become an academic your wife would have
had an affair with your brother or your best
friend."
Alternate Ithaca Tom is crushed.
He's just found out that his wife is having an affair with his research partner. This is the guy's been working with for
15 years. It's a long-term affair. They're moving in together. She's taking the
kids. He's completely crushed, poor alternate Ithaca Tom. He starts drinking.
He can't keep his lecture notes together. He can't keep his research together. He's coming up for tenure and it's all
falling apart. And in the midst
of his turmoil, he's suddenly pierced by this vision of himself
driving a Volkswagen
van. He's off to camp, to tai
chi camp. He's
not married. He doesn't have kids. He doesn't even have a job.
He's completely free. It looks so good, this image. It pierces him to
his heart, begins to hang
around him and haunt him like a hungry ghost.
Louis.